[Musique]
des Français inquièrent face à ce
délitement de leur système de santé des
soignants soumis aux contraintes d'un
système trop administré et de patients
déboussolés le temps est venu pour que
de ces bancs émergent des mesures
pragmatiques concrètes utiles d'abord
pour nos concitoyens qui en permanence
nous interpellent sur ce sujet mais
aussi pour les professionnels de santé
qui en ville comme à l'hôpital attendent
des évolutions
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro des grands débats pendant une
heure nous allons revivre ensemble
l'examen d'un des débats emblématiques
de cette législature
le 12 juin les députés débutent c'est
l'examen de la proposition de loi visant
à améliorer l'accès aux soins par
l'engagement des professionnels de santé
et derrière ce titre l'objectif c'est
tout simplement de lutter contre les
déserts médicaux et pour cela faut-il
inciter ou obliger les médecins à s'y
installer la proposition de loi a été
déposée par le député Frédéric valthou
député horizon soutenu par la majorité
présidentielle et par le gouvernement
nous le savons tous ici sur ces bancs la
crise de notre système de santé et les
difficultés d'accès aux soins qui en
résulte près de malheureusement pour nos
concitoyens comme pour les soignants des
allures de jour sans fin cette crise est
ancienne c'est un long d'élitement au
ressort complexe qui doit autant au
manque d'anticipation que les visions
malthusienne et conservatrices qu'on
partageait longtemps de nombreux
gouvernements et de nombreux acteurs
représentatifs de la profession pour
autant au-delà des causes sur lesquelles
on pourrait disserter pendant longtemps
mais qui ne sont pas le sujet ce soir
cette crise menace l'un des ciment de
notre pacte républicain la promesse d'un
égal accès pour tous à une prise en
charge médicale qui allie la proximité
la qualité et la graduation des soins en
fonction des besoins le tout dans un
système universel qui doit assurer la
protection de chacun la proposition de
loi que j'ai l'honneur de rapporter
devant vous procède de conviction que
nous sommes nombreux je le sais à
partager sur ses bancs c'est la
conviction qu'il est temps de faire plus
confiance aux acteurs de terrain pour
faire émerger une organisation des soins
à la mesure des besoins et des
aspirations de chaque territoire
c'est la conviction qu'il est temps de
faciliter au plus près du terrain le
partage et les coopérations entre tous
ceux qui directement ou indirectement
participe à cette mission du soin les
professionnels de tout statut bien sûr
mais aussi les collectivités locales les
administrations et les associations de
patients le temps est venu d'accélérer
un virage déjà opéré ces dernières
années notamment par la loi ma santé
2022 voulu par le président Emmanuel
Macron et son premier ministre d'alors
Edouard Philippe qui vise à considérer
que l'avenir de notre système de santé
passe autant par des réformes
structurelles nationales à l'exemple du
sel du financement qui est annoncé pour
le prochain PLFSS que par la
responsabilisation des acteurs de
proximité pour faire émerger des
réponses adaptées aux spécificités de
chaque territoire il revient à l'État au
gouvernement et à la représentation
nationale de définir les règles
générales les prio les priorités
attendues de notre système d'assurance
maladie et de veiller au financement de
l'ensemble mais il revient aux acteurs
de terrain de réfléchir et d'imaginer
ensemble en fonction des besoins propres
à chacun
déclinaison territoriale de ces
priorités nationales
je pense au virage vers la prévention je
pense au meilleur partage de la
permanence des soins je pense encore à
la meilleure répartition des forces
soignantes dans les territoires qui
mieux que les acteurs de terrain
connaissent les besoins en santé de la
population dont ils ont la charge pour
rénover un système de santé trop atomisé
cloisonné déséquilibré avec les acteurs
qui ne portent pas tous les mêmes
obligations avec des avec des secteurs
de la ville et de l'hôpital qui ne
communiquent pas assez et avec trop de
nombreux professionnels qui existent
encore de façon isolée nous sommes
appelés à prendre des mesures fortes
personne n'a toutefois de baguette
magique et tout le monde sait notamment
ici qu'il n'y a pas de solution miracle
pour autant les débats au sein de la
commission des affaires sociales nous
ont montré que sur ce thème primordial
nous pouvions converger vers des
solutions concrètes tant sur des mesures
ciblées que sur des réformes
structurelles place désormais à l'action
et à l'impulsion d'une dynamique
nouvelle pour renforcer l'accès aux
soins et rénover nos systèmes de santé
qui compte encore quoi qu'en disent
certains parmi nos trésors nationaux la
proposition de loi que nous allons
examiner aujourd'hui a pour vocation à
faire d'abord confiance à intelligence
collective et à la créativité du terrain
pour faire émerger des stratégies en
santé adaptées à chaque territoire ces
principes sont l'ADN de ce texte
l'article premier organise le dialogue
la concertation et le partage de
stratégie commune en santé en donnant du
poids et du sens au Conseil territoriaux
de santé créé par la loi de Marisol
Touraine de 2016 ses conseils
territoriaux de santé sont aujourd'hui
souvent des coquilles vides demain cela
ne sera plus le cas puisqu'ils auront
pour mission d'élaborer le projet
territorial de santé d'assurer son suivi
ainsi que l'évaluation de sa mise en
oeuvre en lien avec les agences
régionales de santé afin de donner du
sens à la gouvernance territoriale il
définiront demain les objectifs
prioritaires en matière de permanence
des soins d'accès aux soins et
d'équilibre territorial de l'offre de
soins le dispositif tend à
responsabiliser les acteurs de terrain
sur la nécessaire réduction des
inégalités de densité démographique
c'est une mesure importante à l'heure ou
plus de 1,6 millions de Français
renoncent chaque année à des soins
médicaux
20 ans après la suppression l'obligation
de garde pour les médecins de ville il
est temps que nous opérions à
rééquilibrage entre tous les
professionnels qui doivent pouvoir mieux
participer à la permanence des soins la
permanence des soins en ambulatoire a
été précisée par la par la récente loi
de Stéphanie risques l'article cap de
cette proposition de loi est
complémentaire de cette disposition
récentes et prévoit que les
établissements de santé privé
participeront davantage à la permanence
des soins aux côtés des hôpitaux il
s'agit d'une mesure de bon sens soutenue
par les représentants des établissements
privés la principale difficulté de notre
système de santé tient aussi à la
démographie médicale nous n'avons pas
assez de professionnels de santé pour
répondre aux besoins et les années qui
viennent s'annoncent encore plus
difficile avec des tensions extrêmes
dans les zones sous dotées notamment
l'article 5 étant ainsi le contrat
d'engagement de service public à tous
les professionnels en médecine ont
d’autologie maïeutique et pharmacie à
l'issue de la deuxième année du premier
cycle des études de santé ce qui
constitue un plus pour lutter contre les
déserts médicaux
parce que le maintien de l'offre de
soins dans un territoire donné est une
priorité les articles 9 et 10 qui ont
d'ailleurs fait l'objet d'un dialogue
étroit avec l'ensemble des ordres
concernés et les syndicats des padus
vise à renforcer l'intégration des
praticiens à diplôme hors Union
Européenne leur exercice sera alors
facilité avec l'autre croix selon les
cas d'une autorisation d'exercice
provisoire ou d'une nouvelle carte de
séjour plus réelle
l'article 7 de son côté vise à interdire
l'exercice de l'intérim en début de
carrière pour tous les soignants ce
dispositif permet aux jeunes
professionnels d'accéder à des modes
d'exercice stables et de ne pas
augmenter la pénurie sur les postes de
titulaire aussi bien des établissements
de santé que dans les cabinets de ville
chers collègues je sais au combien le
sujet de la santé nous touche tous dans
nos circonscriptions le nombre
d'amendements déposés par les députés de
tous les groupes le montre bel et bien
l'amélioration de l'accès aux soins ne
peut être l'oeuvre d'un seul parti
politique et je me réjouis de la
co-construction sur ce texte en amont de
sa discussion ce soir
Alexandre bien sûr des auditions
nombreuses auxquelles j'ai procédé mais
aussi des discussions nourries
fructueuses que j'ai eu avec le groupe
de travail conduit à la fois par
Guillaume Garraud et Philippe bigier
étant d'autres ces discussions ont
permis de dessiner de nombreuses
convergences je remercie ainsi les
parlementaires pour la qualité des
débats en commission des affaires
sociales de leur volonté de faire bouger
les lignes en proposant les solutions
concrètes sans faire de l'obstruction à
l'heure où la santé et la préoccupation
majeure des Français je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur François Braun
ministre de la Santé de la prévention
le fonctionnement de notre système de
santé est complexe trop administré trop
centralisé
je crois qu'il y a deux temps dans
l'histoire de notre système de santé et
plus largement de nos institutions
j'ai un immense respect pour ceux qui
ont bâti notre système national de
protection sociale à l'époque où nous
avions besoin d'un pouvoir central
directeur et exhaustif pour reconstruire
un pays meurtri faire le constat
aujourd'hui des limites de ce modèle ne
revient pas à nier la grandeur des
choses érigées au contraire moderniser
le fonctionnement de notre système de
santé pour l'adapter au défi et aux
réalités de notre temps est une
nécessité pour le préserver et pour que
la promesse intangible de soins adaptés
et de qualité accessible pour tous et
partout continue de bénéficier aux
générations actuelles et futures
c'est réunir ces deux temps de notre
histoire
le moment tout à fait exceptionnel de la
crise sanitaire de la colite 19 a imposé
ce fait avec une acuité nouvelle alors
qu'au fil des vagues épidémiques ont été
inventés partout en France de nouvelles
solutions et que localement se sont
tissés des solidarités nouvelles
ce dont notre pays et notre système de
santé a besoin en 2023 c'est d'ouverture
d'agilité et de confiance pour les
acteurs de santé et dans les territoires
et tout cela au service des Françaises
et des Français
j'y reviendrai mais rien ne serait pire
que de lier dans la loi les mains des
acteurs de la santé les empêchant
d'avoir cette agilité si essentielle
face aux défis que nous connaissons
en effet si l'État doit rester le garant
des valeurs qui fondent notre système et
que c'est au niveau national que doivent
être définies des grandes priorités
l'enjeu est aujourd'hui de faciliter
l'émergence de réponse territoriale
avec communic horizon l'amélioration de
l'accès aux soins et la lutte contre
toutes les inégalités de santé notamment
géographiques
pour transformer le fonctionnement et
l'organisation territoriale de notre
système de santé afin qu'il réponde à
ses objectifs il n'y a pas vous l'avez
dit monsieur le rapporteur de solutions
miracle
nous faisons face à une crise
démographique il ne s'agit pas ici de
régler des comptes à posteriori mais
dénoncer un fait
nous avons trop longtemps voulu
rationner l'offre pour réduire les coûts
notamment à travers le numerus clausus
c'est un acquis important de cette
majorité de l'avoir supprimé lors du
mandat précédent nous conduisant
progressivement à former plus de
professionnels déjà plus 15% par an en
moyenne
je le sais cela n'est pas encore assez
je sais aussi combien cette solution
pèse sur les soignants et que certains
font face à des situations de véritables
épuisement j'en suis bien conscient et
nous allons continuer collectivement les
forts je pense notamment à ce que nous
faisons avec les régions pour former
plus
mais je tiens à le dire nous ne
supprimerons pas les déserts médicaux et
nous ne réglerons pas les difficultés
structurelles qui parcourent notre
système de santé d'un coup de baguette
le dire serait faux le faire croire
serait malhonnête
la notion d'engagement territorial qui
est le fil rouge de cette proposition de
Loire recouvre bien sûr la volonté
d'embarquer tous les acteurs d'un
territoire et de les impliquer plus
largement mais l'engagement territorial
est aussi synonyme de responsabilité
parce que les problèmes sont collectifs
et que la santé est résolument l'affaire
de tous il faut que chacun partage le
diagnostic l'évolution des besoins et
participe à la réponse c'est une
condition sinequanone du succès de cette
démarche
cette démarche d'engagement et de
responsabilité j'y crois fermement et
surtout je suis convaincu que c'est la
seule qui est de nature à apporter une
réponse efficace et durable
cette démarche je l'oppose à ceux qui
appellent de leurs vœux des mesures de
coercition pour empêcher les médecins à
s'installer à tel ou tel endroit
si cela peut sembler un remède attractif
à court terme et politiquement porteur
créer des rigidités et des contraintes
sera totalement contre-productif et ne
ferait que détourner plus encore de
l'exercice de la médecine et en
particulier de la médecine générale dont
nous savons qu'elle constitue un pilier
incontournable de l'accès à la santé de
nos concitoyens ces débats heurtent nos
médecins
la semaine dernière encore un Mauguio
dans les héros j'ai pu échanger avec des
médecins généralistes de terrain qui
m'ont dit leur désarroi face au débat
nationaux il s'implique pourtant sans
compter au service de leur patient ils
sont les premiers meurtris quand ils
doivent refuser un patient ils ne sont
pas responsables des choix du passé tout
comme les jeunes étudiants et non pas
vocation à résoudre toutes les carences
causées par d'autres
j'ai du respect pour les médecins
généralistes et pour les médecins
libéraux de France je connais les
difficultés des frustrations qui visent
au quotidien mais aussi le lien
privilégié qu'ils ont avec leur patient
les médecins généralistes assument plus
de 230 millions de consultations prises
en charge par la sécurité sociale
ne privant pas les Français de l'accès à
des soins remboursés dont ils ont besoin
oui l'accès à la santé est un enjeu
majeur et difficile mais prenons
collectivement garde une loi trop fermée
trop rigide peut nous empêcher d'agir
efficacement dans les territoires ne
rédissons pas et ne sur-administreront
pas la santé Mesdames et Messieurs les
parlementaires nous avons pu construire
ensemble des apports pertinents au texte
aussi bien avec la majorité qu'avec les
oppositions constructives preuve que
sans renier nos différences politiques
nous pouvons travailler au service de
l'intégrer général au fond le seul qui
compte
je ne doute pas que cet état d'esprit
sera le nôtre pour l'ensemble des débats
à venir je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
depuis un an à l'Assemblée un groupe
d'études transpartisans travaillent lui
aussi sur les déserts médicaux il a
déposé sa propre proposition de loi
portée par le député socialiste
Guillaume Garo mais le texte n'a pas été
inscrit à l'ordre du jour alors les
députés de ce groupe comptent bien faire
entendre leur voix pendant les débats
notamment à travers des amendements et
destinés à restreindre la liberté
d'installation des médecins
nous légiférons cette semaine sur une
question qui touche au cœur de la vie
des Français
cette question c'est celle des déserts
médicaux je vous parle là de la vie des
gens je vous parle là d'une réalité
d'une angoisse d'une détresse parfois
qui touche au moins 8 millions de
Français
quand on n'arrive pas à trouver de
médecin généraliste quand on attend des
mois avant d'avoir un rendez-vous chez
le spécialiste quand on désespère d'être
pris en charge par un dentiste
trois fois plus de généraliste par
habitant dans les Hautes-Alpes que dans
l'Eure
18 fois plus d'ophtalmo à Paris par
habitant que dans la Creuse 23 fois plus
de dermatologue à Paris que dans la
Nièvre c'est ça la réalité de
l'inégalité d'accès aux soins et
ces écarts et nous le savons c'est une
entaille
béante dans le pacte social
hérité du Conseil National de la
Résistance dans la promesse d'égalité
dans l'accès aux soins qui est au
fondement de notre sécurité sociale et
j'ose le dire de notre République c'est
même une nouvelle insécurité sociale qui
exacerbe un sentiment d'abandon dans les
territoires directement concernés alors
je l'ai dit et je vais le répéter ce
soir chaque fois que les déserts
médicaux avancent c'est la République
qui recule
et je le dis
[Applaudissements]
c'est un échec collectif c'est un échec
collectif de notre pays de n'avoir pas
su
anticiper ni apporter les bonnes
réponses mais aujourd'hui chers
collègues on ne peut plus temporiser on
ne peut plus dire à ce ne sera qu'un
mauvais moment à passer il y a urgence
et face à l'urgence nous avons voulu
nous unir à l'Assemblée nationale et
porter ensemble des solutions c'est
précisément ce que nous faisons dans le
cadre de ce groupe de travail trans
partisan et je veux remercier ce soir
ici publiquement
tous les collègues pour leur engagement
résolu infaillible et solidaire depuis
maintenant près d'un an nous avons
nourri nos échanges avec des auditions
près d'une quarantaine d'auditions avec
l'ensemble des parties prenantes nous
avons abouti ça a été très bien dit
avant moi à une proposition de loi
transpartisanes qui hélas n'a jamais pu
être inscrite ici à l'ordre du jour de
l'assemblée mais
nous nous sommes pas découragés et nous
avons repris l'ensemble de ces articles
à travers des amendements que nous
allons défendre devant vous à partir de
ce soir et nous défendrons avec plus de
200 collègues députés
issus des bancs de la gauche de la
droite du Centre et bien nous défendrons
la régulation de l'installation des
médecins
généralistes spécialiste et des
chirurgiens dentistes alors ça a été
très bien dit avant moi bien sûr qu'il y
a pas de remède miracle bien sûr que
personne n'a de baguettes magiques mais
ce que nous vous demandons
madame la ministre monsieur le ministre
monsieur le rapporteur c'est de
considérer l'ensemble des solutions à
notre disposition pour les articuler
c'est bien sûr l'incitation c'est bien
sûr le travail en équipe c'est bien sûr
l'engagement territorial des
professionnels c'est bien sûr la
démocratisation des études mais c'est
aussi la régulation aujourd'hui dans
notre pays le principe d'égalité
n'existe pas en matière de santé
si vous cherchez un ou une dermatologue
vous en trouverez un pour cent mille
habitants dans l'un ou l'Ariège 15 fois
plus à Paris si vous cherchez un ou une
dentiste vous en trouverez 30 %.000
habitants dans la Somme ou ancienne
Saint-Denis trois fois plus dans les
alpes maritimes ou à Paris et si vous
cherchez un ou une gynéco dans les trois
prochains jours doctolib vous propose
140 rendez-vous dans la circonscription
de Monsieur cioti par exemple à Nice 45
dans la mienne en Haute-Garonne et deux
dans la circonscription de ma collègue
Mathilde lignée en Ille-et-Vilaine dès
lors que propose ce texte monsieur le
rapporteur pour garantir améliorer
l'accès aux soins une transformation du
système de santé à savoir qu'une
instance de démocratie sanitaire qui
réunit autour de la table un ensemble
d'acteurs locaux se mettent à piloter
l'organisation des soins nous y voyons à
ce stade quelques risques que le débat
doit permettre d'encadrer
car aucune garantie d'égalité des soins
n'est possible si chaque territoire
s'occupe personnellement de manière
privative dirige de ses propres affaires
car si l'agence régionale de santé
n'intervient qu'en second rang les
territoires s'éloigneront les uns des
autres selon que les professionnels qui
exercent sont déjà une habitude
préalable de travail une habitude
devrait ensemble ou qu'au contraire tout
soit à construire et à bâtir si
l'analyse n'est donc pas totalement
convergente entre nous nous jouons le
jeu sur ce texte et nos propositions
d'un nombre vous l'aurez remarqué très
réduit
propose de remettre votre intuition dans
les rails de la démocratie sanitaire
française car finalement sous ce texte
il y a une question de méthode nous
sommes plus de 200 dans ce Parlement à
avoir signé qu'a signé une proposition
de loi contre les déserts médicaux dans
le cadre d'un groupe de travail
transpartisan qui réunit les députés de
l'ensemble des groupes républicains de
cette émission
elle n'a pas pu être examinée monsieur
Valtou vous nous offrez ce soir
l'opportunité nous voici donc avec
quelques amendements qui en sont issus
et rassemble extrêmement large autour de
trois propositions extrêmement simples
d'abord réguler l'installation des
médecins comme on le fait pour les
pharmacies comme on le fait pour les
sages-femmes comme on le fait en
Allemagne au Royaume-Uni afin que
chacune et chacun dispose à proximité de
son domicile d'une offre de soins c'est
tout c'est là le principe pleine et
entier de la régulation de
l'installation
la méthode n'a rien ni de brutal ni de
bureaucratique chacune et chacun aurait
le droit de s'installer dans toute zone
sous dotée du pays j'entends dire que la
France ne serait qu'un grand désert
médical tant mieux il pourra aller
partout c'est cela est vrai ou alors de
remplacer un départ dans une zone qui
elle est d'ores et déjà bien dotée une
proposition qui ne ferait donc que des
gagnants et des gagnants puisque là où
l'état du système de santé et la
couverture est la plus avancée il y
aurait un maintien là où elle est plus
défaillante il y aurait de nouvelles
arrivées
la proposition de loi prévoit d'autres
mesures pour lutter contre les déserts
médicaux elle renforce notamment la
responsabilité des professionnels de
santé à l'échelon locale pour renforcer
l'accès aux soins y compris le soir et
le weekend
je suis pas sûr que
la notion de territoire se suffisamment
clairement définie en tout cas pas dans
notre esprit parce que tel que vous le
dites si c'est le préfet on imagine que
c'est à l'échelle du département que
vous organisez un territoire donc il y a
quelque chose de de d'un peu d'un peu
flou dans cette notion de territoire
donc j'aimerais savoir un peu comment
vous voyez les choses
vous aurez remarqué qu'au tout début de
l'article premier on explique que la
délimitation des territoires de santé
peut-être redéfinie par les membres
siégeants au sein des conseils
territoriaux de santé compétents en lien
avec l'agence régionale de santé et on
dit aussi dans le même article que cet
article ce s'applique 10 mois après la
provocation de la loi donc en fait on
ouvre un délai de 10 mois pendant lequel
les acteurs du territoire peuvent se
saisir des périmètres actuels des cts
sin leur semblent pas pertinent pour le
redéfinir je le redis est-ce que c'est
une métropole est-ce que c'est un
département est-ce que c'est un
département divisé en trois territoires
de santé moi je connais pas la
géographie de chaque département en
matière de santé j'en sais rien et donc
chacun pourra juger en fonction
effectivement de ce qui lui semble
pertinent lorsqu'ils santé quel est la
notion de territoire lorsqu'on parle
santé ça c'est un sujet effectivement
qui appartient aux acteurs de territoire
et pas ni à moi rapporteur
cet article 1 il définit des territoires
de santé effectivement je pense que nous
sommes tous une énigmes à dire que il
est important effectivement de coller
aussi à la réalité au travers ces
territoires de santé nul ne remet en
cause l'intérêt de les définir et de les
prendre en compte parce que
effectivement il y a des diversités de
situations je crois que vous l'avez dit
à plusieurs reprises sur le ministre et
il est important d'établir une
différenciation finalement des
politiques à conduire en fonction ces
diversités de situation qui peuvent
exister donc il convient pour cela
effectivement d'avoir le périmètre le
plus pertinent pour coller au besoin
pour répondre aux préoccupations et aux
situations diverses et c'est vrai que la
notion de région cette ce périmètre est
très vaste avec des situations très
diverses à l'intérieur et je pense qu'il
est important d'arriver de coller près
de la réalité au plus près du terrain et
le département nous paraît tout à fait
pertinent par rapport à tous ces
amendements qui ont été présentés je
crois qu'il faut pas magnifier le
l'espace départemental d'abord il faut
se rassurer infra régional ça veut pas
dire régional donc un frein régional ça
laisse la liberté aux acteurs de terrain
de d'organiser les périmètres selon la
pertinence de ces périmètres en matière
de politique de santé le bassin de vie
en matière de santé la cohérence en
matière de santé c'est sans doute
peut-être à un endroit le département à
un autre endroit c'est du enfin pardon
mais chez moi qui suis francilien
l'espace départemental ne veut rien dire
donc peut-être que dans d'autres régions
l'espace départemental a une pertinence
ce que je voudrais pas c'est que le
législateur dans sa gourmandise
rédactionnelle fixe lui-même des
périmètres là entre nous alors que on
essaie de faire un un texte qui doit
partir du terrain et laisser la liberté
aux acteurs de terrain d'organiser des
périmètres là où le semble pertinent et
je pense pas que la pertinence des
territoires nous puissions la décider
ici à Paris dans cette hémicycle et donc
je je trouve que la rédaction telle
qu'elle est proposée d'infras régional
permet au contraire de donner cet espace
de liberté certains voudront conserver
l'espace départemental grand bien leur
face d'autres voudront parce qu'il y a
des métropoles parce qu'il y a des aires
urbaines parce que il y a des cohérences
géographiques différentes et bien
organisé d'autres périmètres et au moins
comme ça le le l'article le permet donc
défavorable à tous ces amendements
très vite les débattes s'orientent vers
une question faut-il ou non réguler
l'installation des médecins deux
amendements proposent de conditionner ou
de moduler le conventionnement des
médecins en fonction de la zone où ils
exercent afin de très fortement les
inciter à s'installer dans des zones
sous dotées
voici le premier amendement qui concerne
alors on appellera ça modulation
régulation conventionnellement sélectif
personnellement c'est un amendement que
je vais voter
parce que depuis trop longtemps dans
cette hémicique de l'Assemblée nationale
nous nous sommes bornés aux mesures
dites incitatives pour faire venir les
médecins sur l'ensemble du territoire le
constat est que les mesures dites
incitatives sont insuffisantes il faut
donc maintenant s'employer au côté des
mesures assez initiatives que l'on peut
renforcer et améliorer avoir des mesures
dites de régulation et l'amendement 233
de notre collègue Cormier bouligeon
vise à conventionner l'installation des
professionnels de santé plus
particulièrement les médecins là où il y
en a besoin de nos jours tous les
métiers sont soumis à régulation tous
les métiers sont soumis à autorisation
je pense que ouvrir la voie à travers un
amendement de déconventionnement on est
simplement en train de mettre en place
une médecine à deux vitesses et ceux qui
pourront finalement se payer des
médecins des conventionnés et bien ça ne
réglera en rien la démographie médicale
et surtout ça répartition et je dirais
aux collègues qui disent que depuis des
années rien n'a été fait en faisant de
façon incitatif je dirais juste que le
monde a changé que les générations de
médecins ont changé que le rapport au
travail a changé qu'il y a eu la crise
sanitaire qui a beaucoup de choses qui
ont changé et que je pense qu'on prend
surtout le risque de les faire déplaquer
de les faire se déconventionner et se
faire détourner donc je pense que là il
faut être raisonnable et c'est pas par
la coercition qu'on y arrivera s'agit
un amendement important à nos yeux et
qui rejoint je pense des préoccupations
largement exprimées dans dans cette
hémicycle puisque c'est ce que nous
appelons le conventionnement sélectif
une proposition que nous portons depuis
fort longtemps qui vise tout simplement
à ce que on ne puisse s'installer dans
une zone surdence que si un médecin s'en
va voilà c'est une mesure de régulation
somme toute assez modeste mais qui
permet à l'état de se doter d'un outil
supplémentaire pour essayer d'assurer
l'accès aux soins le mieux possible dans
tout le pays car nous avons la
responsabilité l'État à la
responsabilité d'assurer l'accès aux
soins et donc il nous semble que cette
mesure de régulation pourrait être un
outil
utile dans cette bataille qui doit être
menée pour que chacune et chacun puisse
avoir tout simplement le droit à la
santé
qu'est-ce qu'une zone sur dense est-ce
que ici dans cette hémicycle
un parlementaire peut lever la main et
me dire que dans son sa circonscription
il y a trop de médecins il est dans une
zone sur dense
je vous le demande à un je retiens 1
donc je saurai ou aller chercher des
médecins
bon visiblement dans l'hémicycle il n'y
en a pas
je reprends simplement mon exemple
je reprends mon exemple allemand
62%.000 habitants si vous avez plus de
médecins que 62% mille en Allemagne vous
êtes dans une zone sur dense je le redis
ça veut dire que toutes les zones sont
surnomes en France mais derrière cette
remarque il y a quoi il y a de dire que
ce n'est pas tant le nombre de médecins
qui nous posent problème aujourd'hui et
ce nombre de médecins vous le savez
comme moi il ne va pas augmenter avant
au moins une dizaine d'années ce qu'il
nous faut c'est redonner au médecin du
temps médical toutes les mesures que
nous avons prises toutes les mesures qui
ont été votées ici dans le cadre de la
loire-riste amène à donner du temps
médical c'est ça qui est important c'est
comme ça que nous allons progressivement
résoudre entre autres la problématique
des déserts médicaux qui est une plaie
aujourd'hui dans notre système de santé
allez vers de la contrainte aller vers
du conventionnement sélectif je le redis
c'est aggraver l'offre de soins diminuer
cette offre de soin et ça ça ne va pas
attendre 5 ans ou 10 ans ce sera dès la
rentrée prochaine que nous allons
dégrader l'offre de soins avec des
jeunes qui ne s'installeront plus à vie
bien sûr défavorable le scrutin est
ouvert
le scrutin est clos
les résultats votant 189 exprimés 175
majorité 88 pour 17 contre 158 il n'est
pas adopté
si tous les députés sont préoccupés par
les déserts médicaux il ne s'accorde pas
sur les solutions à
yapa alors que Frédéric va tout y est
fermement opposé car il l'estime
contre-productive Guillaume carreau va
défendre la mesure centrale de sa
proposition de loi à savoir la
régulation de l'installation des
médecins les députés du groupe d'études
transpartisans lui emboîte le pas
je défends ici un amendement au nom du
groupe de travail transpartisan que nous
avons constitué ici à l'Assemblée voilà
près d'un an
et je voudrais présenter
le sens de la
régulation de l'installation tel que
nous la proposons d'abord il faut dire
ce qu'elle n'est pas cette régulation ce
que nous proposons ce n'est pas
d'affecter les médecins ici ou là j'ai
entendu des choses qui étaient
parfaitement fausses de ce point de vue
nous n'allons pas nommer un médecin dans
tel ou tel territoire en revanche ce que
nous disons c'est la chose suivante nous
disons à nos médecins
n'allez plus vous installer là où les
besoins de soins sont déjà pourvus
mais allez vous installer où vous
voudrez
ailleurs là où les besoins de santé ne
sont pas pourvus là où vos patients vous
attendent
c'est l'idée cette régulation que nous
devons aujourd'hui
organiser l'installation en fonction des
besoins de santé des territoires
et pour cela nous proposons un régime
d'autorisation qui serait accordé ou pas
par les agences régionales de santé
pourquoi nous faisons cette proposition
pour une raison simple nous partons du
constat de ce que nous vivons de ce que
vivent des millions de Français
aujourd'hui
on fait tous la même démonstration je
crois les uns les autres c'est que les
politiques d'un citation qui ont été
menées depuis des années depuis des
dizaines d'années non pas produit les
résultats qu'on attendait cette
régulation ce n'est pas une punition
pour les médecins mais c'est une
solution pour les Français parallèlement
et en complément des incitations une
solution qui a fait ses preuves pour
d'autres professions telles que les
infirmiers les kinés et les pharmaciens
et qui fonctionnent dans d'autres pays
tels que la Belgique le Danemark ou le
Québec vous savez ce n'est pas de Gai
des cœurs que nous en arrivons en cette
proposition de régulation que nous avons
travaillé avec le groupe transpartisan
car personnellement je crois je suis
attaché à la médecine libérale et donc à
la liberté d'installation mais en
arrivait à cette proposition de
régulation et tout simplement devenu un
impératif c'est un véritable cri de
détresse des élus de la population qui
se passe aujourd'hui en séance et tout à
fait
extraordinaire et intéressant puisque je
suis là défendre un amendement qui
rigoureusement le même que celui qu'on
défendu juste avant moi les collègues
Favennec ou Vigier qui ne siègent pas
sur le dans le même groupe que moi
parfois même pas du tout dans le même
groupe que moi et pourtant nous nous
retrouvons sur ce type de mesure qui
suscite un consensus transpartisant
extrêmement large partout où l'offre de
soins et bonne en zone surdosée et bien
nous garantissons le maintien de cet
offre par une politique de remplacement
systématique des partantes et des
partants partout en revanche ou l'offre
est insuffisante et bien les
professionnels peuvent venir s'installer
c'est une politique une mesure qui ne
fait que des gagnantes et des gagnants
mais c'est le ministre
il est des moments où il faut essayer
des voix qu'on a jamais essayé et nul ne
peut dire le contraire nul ne peut dire
le contraire
alors donc
osons ensemble essayons ensemble et je
dis enfin rassemblement national parce
que ce sujet est un sujet majeur dans
toutes les circonscriptions rurales et
bien une fois de plus vous aurez montré
que vous êtes dans le renoncement
national à tout moment jamais le courage
jamais au nom de quoi avec zéro
proposition alors il faut
à ce moment là quel que soit les idées
des uns et des autres et moi je respecte
les avis contraires peut-être que dans
les années 2030 il faudra mettre en
place un système qui nous permet
d'éviter les erreurs du passé quelles
ont été ces erreurs du passé et bien de
voir effectivement s'installer dans des
territoires qui sont parfois les mêmes
dans des territoires peu nombreux de
voir s'installer de te voir se
concentrer l'offre médicale parce que
effectivement la main visible du marché
n'a pas bien joué et effectivement
l'installation et c'est ce sont ils se
sont éparpillés aux quatre coins du
territoire en privilégiant certains
territoires les plus attractifs alors
oui je suis pas contre effectivement
qu'on se comprenne le temps et avec les
professionnels pour inventer un système
qui permette et bien d'assurer une
meilleure répartition des forces
médicales dans le territoire mais
l'enjeu d'ici là et c'est là-dessus que
je voudrais insister l'enjeu de d'ici là
contenu de la des difficultés
démographiques c'est de garder avec nous
nos soignants nous en avons de moins en
moins je l'ai expliqué j'ai donné les
chiffres si nous perdons nos soignants
alors nous aurons pas réussi
effectivement à améliorer l'accès aux
soins des Français et donc c'est un
message de confiance c'est un message de
confiance et de responsabilité que l'on
donne aussi aux soignants à travers
cette proposition loi et notamment
maintenant au moment de ce débat mais
au-delà c'est d'abord un signal que l'on
envoie à la jeunesse vous êtes tous très
attentifs sur ces vents et vous avez
raison d'adresser des signaux positifs à
la jeunesse par rapport à leur métier
par rapport à l'engagement dans leur
société par rapport à leurs conditions
de vie actuelle et future le débat que
nous avons là c'est pas un débat
vis-à-vis de ceux qui depuis 30 ans
s'entassent dans certaines villes
attractives effectivement et qui quoi
qu'il arrive resteront dans ces villes
attractives et dérouleront leurs
carrière comme bon leur somme dans ses
villes attractives je parle de tous ces
médecins qui sont effectivement en
surpopulation dans certains territoires
mais là nous parlons pas d'eux parce que
cela on va pas les déranger moi je parle
des jeunes et je parle de ceux qui
effectivement demain sont l'avenir de la
prise en charge des Français alors qu'on
leur demande pas trop de porter le
chapeau de ce que les générations
précédentes n'ont pas fait qu'on leur
demande pas trop de porter la
responsabilité de ce que les
gouvernements passés n'ont pas
osé faire peut-être qu'on leur demande
pas trop de porter la responsabilité
d'un certain nombre de
dysfonctionnements que vous avez tous
rappelés que vous avez tous rappelés à
juste titre mais qui aujourd'hui il
serait dont il serait responsable voilà
c'est le message que je souhaitais
donner bien sûr je suis défavorable à
ces amendements avis défavorables sur
les amendements un et identiques double
avis défavorable scrutin est ouvert
résultat votant 304 exprimé 295 majorité
148 pour 127 contre 168 l'Assemblée
nationale n'a pas adopté
[Applaudissements]
finalement la mesure est rejetée mais
les députés du groupe de travail
transpartisans vont réussir à convaincre
la majorité et le gouvernement sur
d'autres mesures comme la possibilité
pour les agences régionales de santé de
salariés des médecins ou la fin de la
majoration tarifaire pour les personnes
qui ne trouvent pas de médecins traitant
dans les déserts médicaux
l'objectif est de permettre aux ARS pour
améliorer les conditions d'accès aux
soins notamment de salariés des médecins
c'est une présente pas ici ça comme la
panacée la réponse à tout mais en tout
cas c'est aussi une réponse aux attentes
des gens dans certains coins on aura
beaucoup de mal à avoir des médecins qui
s'installent en libéral c'est permettre
notamment aux jeux de médecin de s'y
installer rapidement donc c'est une
attente des gens qui manquent de mettre
aux gens qui manquent de médecins c'est
aussi d'une part répondre aux attentes
des maires aujourd'hui dans les
communautés de communes qui ce qui se
qui se bagarrent pour essayer de
d'installer des centres de santé etc
c'est l'arrêt des médecins mais on pense
que ce n'est pas le rôle ça ça doit être
le rôle normalement de la sécurité
sociale de pouvoir faire en sorte de
salariés les médecins c'est pas le c'est
pas le rôle des élus locaux un avis
favorable sur ces amendements évidemment
j'essaie d'avoir une certaine cohérence
mais aussi j'essaie d'avoir une certaine
cohérence par rapport à au travail de
préparation qui a pu être fait autour de
ce texte travail qui nous a permis avec
un certain nombre de personnes qui
réfléchissent sur ces sujets sur les
différents bancs de cette émission avec
qui sont les plus particulièrement
investis mais aussi en concertation avec
évidemment les cossignataires de cette
profession loi avec le gouvernement et
bien de faire mûrir un certain nombre de
propositions ça en fait partie donc je
me félicite de ce travail et cette ces
amendements en sont une des
illustrations il s'agit comme ça a été
dit auparavant par cet amendement qui
est issu des travaux du groupe de
travail transpartisan de mettre fin à
une forme de double peine qui règne dans
notre pays ce qu'on appelle la
majoration tarifaire pour les personnes
qui n'ont pas de médecin traitant cette
majoration tarifaire elle constitue une
double peine je le disais pour la raison
suivante c'est que lorsque vous êtes sur
un territoire où il est compliqué de
trouver un professionnel ou une
professionnelle de santé auprès duquel
auprès de laquelle s'inscrit enfin
auprès duquel auprès de laquelle
personne a désigné on va dire comme
votre médecin traitant et bien non
seulement cette difficulté de distance
d'accès etc joue sur votre recours au
soir mais en plus lorsque vous y
parvenez enfin vous avez une majoration
financière donc ça veut dire qu'on vous
fait payer le prix de l'inaccessibilité
d'un service public de santé qui est
défaillant donc ça ça plaide évidemment
pour mettre fin à ce type d'injustice je
salue encore une fois ce pas en avant
collectif sans préjugés bien sûr des
autres passes c'est un élément du du
dispositif et en entendant ces débats je
me félicite d'avoir pu lever le gaz et
donner cette possibilité en ce qui
concerne les patients qui sont sans
mettre un traitant je voudrais vous
rappeler et trop peu de nos concitoyens
de savent que j'ai passé une instruction
au Caisse Primaire d'Assurance Maladie
pour que cette majoration soit appliquée
avec discernement le scrutin est ouvert
vos temps 75 exprimés 75 majorité 38
pour 75 contre 0 l'Assemblée nationale a
adopté et il fait comme hier écrit tout
l'article il fait tomber les autres
amendements et je n'ai plus besoin de
mettre au bois cet article
à l'issue des débats les groupes de la
majorité sont les seuls à voter le texte
mais lors des explications de votre le
travail mené pendant les débats et
saluer sur différents bons de
l'hémicycle
je pense que le premier point à
souligner ce soir c'est qu'on a été
capable collectivement de porter un
travail que j'ai qualifie du positif et
constructif on l'a fait parce qu'il
écoute réciproque parce qu'il y a eu un
travail de fond qui a été fait pendant
de longs mois et ensuite des discussions
avec le rapporteur avec le gouvernement
avec d'autres groupes de manière à ce
qu'on soit en capacité d'apporter un
certain nombre de solutions car ce sujet
là et bien il n'est pas un seul
territoire de la République
métropolitaine française et d'outre-mer
qui n'est pas concerné
il y a eu bien sûr des avancées nous
avons des rendez-vous importants qu'on a
franchi ensemble sur la formation sur
l'attractivité de ces métiers sur les
contrats d'engagement de service public
ce n'est soit non programmés monsieur le
ministre
c'est 700 000 LD ces personnes qui n'ont
plus de médecin traitant elle nous
regarde elle nous entend
donc je pense qu'on a fait ensemble les
choix qui sont des choix essentiels pour
faire en sorte que on arrive
emprunter un chemin qui nous rapprochera
un jour d'une solution pour tous et vous
dire enfin on a loupé un schéma c'est
celui de la régulation et j'ai le dis
très clairement c'est dommage parce que
mais oui mais je l'ai entendu à
plusieurs reprises et ce chemin de la
régulation vous verrez que tout a nous
l'emprunterons parce que ça n'est pas un
chemin coercitif c'est un chemin
d'équilibre un chemin d'équilibre parce
que la santé c'est ce qui a de plus
précieux et on doit sur tout le
territoire en toute endroit apporter une
réponse de qualité merci
je veux m'associer
à ce qui vient d'être dit sur la qualité
de nos débats
je crois que ce qui a été la marque de
nos échanges depuis le début de la
semaine et précédemment la semaine
passée en commission c'est le respect le
respect des positions de chacun ce qui
n'a pas empêché d'avancer
et je veux croire que
la constitution de notre groupe de
travail trans partisan n'y est pas
étrangère
je pense véritablement que tout ce que
nous avons fait nous députés de droits
de gauche du centre depuis un an à aider
dans cette façon de faire la loi
ensemble
et je veux dire que non seulement nous
avons pu avancer dans un nouvel état
d'esprit mais nous avons aussi nous
membres du groupe de travail
transpartisan obtenu quelques avancées
nous avons
obtenu des débouchés et je veux les
rappeler brièvement
c'est la création d'un préavis de 6 mois
c'est le guichet unique c'est
la création d'un indicateur territorial
de l'offre de soins c'est
la limitation du cumul des aides c'est
aussi ce soir ça n'a peut-être pas été
noté suffisamment mais la permanence des
soins avec une amplitude qu'on ne voyait
pas qu'on ne voyait plus depuis 2003 ce
sont des avancées ce sont des
améliorations mais il y a un mais
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
rapporteur le texte ce texte c'est aussi
le texte d'une occasion manquée et ça a
été dit avant moi
c'est ce manque de régulation
face au désert médicaux et pourquoi nous
avons défendu la régulation parce que
c'est à nos yeux un vrai levier
d'efficacité de toutes les mesures que
nous avons voté ce soir au cours des
amendements il manque la régulation il
manque l'efficacité mais nous en sommes
là ce soir le texte aura maintenant sa
vie parlementaire ça navette et pour
conclure Madame la Présidente
je veux juste donner la position des
députés socialistes que je représente ce
soir pour dire que nous nous
abstiendrons dans une abstention qui
souhaite que le texte puisse être à
nouveau
enrichi améliorer lorsqu'il sera
présenté au sénateur en tout cas on a
fait la démonstration que
on doit traiter les problèmes des
Français qu'on doit y apporter des
réponses et que celle que nous avons
proposé ont ouvert un chemin je vous
remercie
le travail que nous avons mené depuis le
début de la semaine dans cette hémicycle
aura permis
d'apporter certaines améliorations afin
de permettre l'égalité d'accès aux soins
partout en France
en réalité ce travail a commencé il y a
bientôt un an avec le groupe
transportant le groupe de travail
transpartisans
et là le chemin est encore long et pour
parvenir véritablement à lutter contre
les déserts médicaux je voudrais tout de
même saluer les débats constructifs qui
ont eu lieu d'abord en commission et
dans cette hémicycle
comme quoi débattre par Le Mans c'est
bien possible malheureusement malgré ses
victoires l'Assemblée nationale a loupé
un rendez-vous
celui de la régulation de l'installation
des médecins alors que 75
74% des Français plébiscitent son
application
alors notre combat continuera afin de
convaincre nos collègues que bien loin
d'être une mesure coercitive la
régulation est un outil indispensable à
la lutte contre les déserts médicaux si
cette proposition de loi nous permet
d'avoir un débat sur la médecine de
ville à l'Assemblée il y a encore elle
est encore loin d'engager la grande
réforme dont notre système de santé a
cruellement besoin de plus nous n'avons
pas répondu aux inquiétudes que nous
avons soulevé sur le changement de
gouvernance en matière de santé c'est
pourquoi nous laisserons sachant ce
texte
rendez-vous pris donc pour continuer le
travail engagé je vous remercie
effectivement je voudrais saluer
également la qualité des débats que ça
soit en commission que ça soit ici dans
l'hémicycle les ouvertures de travail
que monsieur le ministre a pu faire et
que l'on pourra éventuellement reprendre
en commission lors notamment de l'examen
du PVCs 2024 cependant je dois quand
même reconnaître que un certain nombre
d'éléments sont quand même des
repoussoirs pour effectivement que le
groupe les républicains votent ce texte
la conférence territoriale de santé je
les je vous l'ai dit plusieurs fois je
ne crois pas à son utilité je pense que
c'est une strat supplémentaire qui
existe déjà que vous voulez incrémenter
mais je pense que ça n'améliorera en
rien l'offre de soins sur les
territoires l'obligation sur les CPTs je
pense qu'il faut faire attention il faut
que ça vienne par l'incitation et enfin
on a évité de justesse un certain nombre
d'amendements qui portaient plutôt de la
coercition et je crois que nous exprimer
là-dessus nous sommes pour l'incitation
cette incitation passe par de la
formation le problème des déserts
médicaux et quantitatives donc je pense
que effectivement on pourrait peut-être
un jour envisager cette régulation mais
certainement pas quand le nombre de
médecins est au plus bas donc pour
l'ensemble de ces raisons nous n'irons
pas vers un vote de cette ppm merci je
voulais remercier l'ensemble des
participants à ce débat et souligner la
qualité des débats et dire que de
l'autre côté nous avons été très
satisfaits de faire preuve d'ouverture
et d'essayer de co-construire cette loi
voilà
le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin est clos
voici le résultat du scrutin votant 66
s'exprimer 41 majorité 21 pour 37 contre
4 l'Assemblée nationale a adopté
monsieur le rapporteur vous souhaitiez
prendre la parole
oui merci madame la Présidente bien sûr
je voudrais vous adresser il est tard je
vais être bref mais je peux pas clore
une semaine de débat sans d'abord vous
adresser à tous des remerciements des
remerciements d'abord au députés de mon
groupe qui depuis le début soutiennent
la démarche et en ayant bien sûr une
pensée pour Thomas Meunier au député
notre qui ont consigné la la proposition
de loi initiale et évidemment les
collègues du groupe Renaissance à
l'ensemble des orateurs qui finalement
depuis une semaine travaille ici ont
travaillé la semaine d'avant à la
commission des affaires sociales dans un
travail qui effectivement a été
fructueux qui a été sérieux qui a été
respectueux pour reprendre le mot de
Guillaume Garraud qui a été un travail
de fond sur un sujet qui en est un aussi
et sur lequel je pense que les Français
nous attendaient
avec les points positifs et d'autres qui
est qui sont estimés négatifs par
certains d'entre vous mais avec lequel
aussi beaucoup de soignants nous nous
attendaient il y a ceux qui ont fait du
bruit parce qu'il protestait il trouvait
que on allait trop loin mais il y a tous
ceux qui n'ont rien dit et je pense
notamment aux soignants hospitaliers qui
soutiennent ce texte et qui ont vu que
les lignes bougent et en tout cas je
sais que ce soit ils sont heureux de
voir que la présentation nationale sur
ce sujet là a fait un travail qui utile
merci aussi aux administrateurs qui ont
fait un travail de fond absolument
formidable pouvez les applaudir parce
que les journées et les nuits ont été
courtes merci aussi à la présidente de
la commission des affaires sociales pour
sa confiance et puis merci à vous deux
membres du gouvernement et et d'avoir
accompagné aussi à la fois les travaux
préparatoires d'avoir permis la
concrétisation de certains dispositifs
je crois que tout ça a été utile je
crois que le sujet qu'on a travaillé
pendant une semaine c'est un sujet qui a
mûri
pendant de longues qui a mûri pendant de
longs mois effectivement à travers
certaines initiatives comme le groupe
qui s'est réunit autour de Guillaume
Garraud incontestablement autour aussi
de toutes les sollicitations que les uns
les autres dans nos circonscriptions ont
recevait jour après jour semaine après
semaine de nos concitoyens qui étaient
perdus face à ce délitement du système
de santé on a fait je pense moi je le
trouve œuvre utile et lignes ont bougé
quand on parle de permanence des soins
quand on parle de effectivement de de
territorialisation du système de santé
quand on parle des contrats d'engagement
de service public je vais pas faire la
liste ici maintenant mais ce sont pour
moi des choses qui sont lourdes de sens
et qui potentiellement si les acteurs de
terrain savent maintenant s'en emparer
peuvent faire réellement bouger les nids
faire évoluer notre système de santé
peut-être bien plus que des grandes lois
cadres générales qu'on a connu très très
bavarde on se rappelle des lois qui
dépassent 150 200 articles parfois et
dont on se finit finalement c'est plus
très bien à quoi elles ont servi parce
que à force d'être BA l'essentiel
j'espère que nous en tout cas en étant
synthétique à travers ces 20 27
vingtaines de de d'articles on a on a
été on a été on a fait
œuvre très concrète donc un immense
merci du fond du cœur j'ai fait du sujet
de la santé comme vous tous d'ailleurs
parce que si les sitars et vous êtes
encore là c'est que vous-même portez
cette même ambition nous avons
collectivement fait chacun de
l'évolution et de l'accompagnement du
service de santé une priorité de notes
dans notre engagement politique je crois
que ce soir nous pouvons être fier du
travail faire en tout cas moi je suis
très fier et puis merci à Jean-François
aussi pour tout le boulot qu'il a fait
pour le gros Renaissance et un super
boulot merci à tous
merci monsieur le rapporteur monsieur le
ministre vous souhaitiez la parole oui
merci madame la Présidente vu de
retardive je serai également très bref
bien sûr je me félicite que ce texte ait
été voté je retiens surtout de ses
journées des débats qui ont été de
grande qualité une discussion large
ouverte sur des enjeux de fonds sans
jamais renier nos convictions ni nos
divergences politiques mais en étant
capable de compromis je tiens bien sûr à
remercier de rapporteur Frédéric valtoul
la commission des affaires sociales avec
sa présidente fadilakatabi et ça
rapporte en général Stéphanie Rist je
tiens surtout à saluer les responsables
de textes des différents groupes et je
veux les citer je pense à Jean-François
Rousset bien entendu Philippe Vigier
guillaume-garo Yannick noder Adrien
Clouet Sébastien Petavy et Pierre
Daredevil
je veux également remercier la ministre
Agnès Firmin le Baudot et saluer les
collaborateurs les services d'assemblée
nationale ceux de mon ministère ainsi
que ceux de mon cabinet merci vraiment à
tous je souhaite que le chemin de cette
PPL continue dans ce même esprit
constructif qui est celui qui donne vie
à la raison d'être de notre engagement
commun améliorer la santé des Français
et lutter contre toutes les inégalités
d'accès aux soins je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
la proposition de loi visant à améliorer
l'accès aux soins par l'engagement des
professionnels de santé a donc été
adoptée une première étape avant son
examen au Sénat c'est la fin de ce
numéro des grands débats à bientôt sur
LCP
[Musique]